well a las vegas man and his son are  facing charges after a cat was shot  dead in the backyard of a home in the  northwest valley last week  carl garcia was booked on charges of  willful malicious killing of a cat  conspiracy to kill another person's  animal and concealing evidence  his son logan garcia also facing charges  of conspiracy and concealing evidence  police say video recordings from a ring  camera  show a cat surrounded by garcia's dogs  logan tried to get the cat out of the  yard but was not successful  another video clip showed carl pumping a  bb gun and firing it  into the cat at close range both men  were released without bail and  are expected in court next month